a few days ago i did a stream where i
was trying to implement stenciling in my
game engine what stenciling is is
basically an outline now all these clips
i had to mute all the audio because i
was playing some music and i don't think
it's gonna fly on youtube i'm just gonna
get you know struck or whatever they do
with
you being not allowed to play music
sorry artist i'd love to support you but
i'm not allowed
and uh yeah so here's the clip of the
beginning before the stenciling now i've
just kind of got a little demo scene
that runs here and it
runs a cube runs a circle uh you can hit
some buttons and also show some animated
models or not
and
yeah i basically wanted to get some
little stencils around that so i took
the time and wrote a bunch of functions
to do all of this
now all of this is from learn opengl for
the most part i did reference some of
kronos's documentation on opengl as well
and i also went to the comments of that
section and learn opengl as there was
some data
and down there that was necessary i had
to do a little bit of my own
implementations
of things as i couldn't exactly go off
all the tutorial data because as you
might know
tutorials never work exactly
perfectly right you always have to still
think critically and use your own
decisions
which i thought most people would know
by now but apparently not i get a lot of
criticism about hey why doesn't this
work perfectly for me and it's usually
because they have a different setup so
you got to adapt accordingly that's
pretty standard
so we did so i had to add another shader
and i had to basically work on my
rendering pipeline for this specific
thing
eventually i will push this code to the
public branch of ancient archer
but i'm still working out some kinks so
it might be a while and also i have some
other stuff i want to implement
so yeah i did this all live on my stream
and it's linked down below in all my
videos so if you want to
follow or
support over there you're welcome to
but yeah just trying to document this
basically because this video is going to
disappear on twitch before too much
longer so i figured i'd get just a
little short
version of it it was a pretty long
stream overall
i spent a lot of time
kind of poking around and taking my time
with it i wasn't trying to rush it i've
always noticed that when i try to rush
and get something done it ends up a lot
worse and i also took some time to add
some extra features i added this feature
where
basically
okay well i guess i gotta go back a
little bit so there's a couple different
ways of doing the stenciling
one of the main ways is you basically
scale up the object a little bit for its
stencil and then you draw the real
object over top of that and what you end
up with is a little stencil behind the
object but this doesn't work perfectly
for all models and mostly models that
aren't centered perfectly like this
little cube here
it's it's okay
it works okay for the stencil with the
resize or the scale method but these
models they don't work so well the
stenciling ends up looking really weird
i don't know if i got any clips of it
here it's kind of hard to find all the
clips i wanted in this like five hour
set of video
but okay there it is doing it with
normals on this cube and you can see it
looks a little awkward so
on on the cube or objects that are have
a proper origin it looks great but for
models like this that animated one you
kind of have to use the normals and that
looks okay
and then comes in another issue where
you got to decide the scale of your
stencil and it seems to vary depending
on how much you've scaled your object
and whether you're using normals to
censor it or you're
you're uh scaling your stencil render
that's
that's a mouthful and i
realize it probably doesn't make much
sense i don't know if there's any way i
can make that make more sense
unfortunately it's you kind of have to
understand the whole stenciling thing so
i would
defer to the learn opengl page if you
want to know more about this and be sure
to read the comments and
you're welcome to leave comments down
here or join the discord if you have
more questions about how to do this
stenciling but basically in the end what
i ended up doing was i added
both options i just said it that so when
you add a model you could choose if you
want to stencil by resize or if you want
to stencil by
and there's there's me afk
great clip great clip glad i left that
in there
i kind of just randomly chose clips in
here to be honest and i just happen to
get this one so
that's fine but you can see he's
slightly stenciled so when stenciling
with the normal on this guy i noticed
that i had to scale it up a lot more
than i did with other things
but
yeah so i just put in options for that
way the programmer can decide you can
decide what kind of stencil you want to
use what color you want to make the
stencil and how much you want to scale
it that way you can play around with it
on your own and get it just right for
the model that you're implementing
and that was pretty much it i pretty
much left it like that
for now and uh overall i think we're
about as good as it's gonna get
so yeah i don't know if there's a whole
lot else to say about this
really it's uh
pretty interesting stuff
and i started to learn a lot more about
frame buffers this really got me
understanding frame buffers and i've
been researching frame buffers more and
i know a lot of you out there probably
think oh you don't know how frame
buffers work yet well i kind of do but
i'm no expert and i'll happily admit
that so i've been learning learning more
and i think i have a decent
understanding of them now
and uh yeah opengl has a lot of options
for these frame buffers and it's a big
part of getting to the next steps of
rendering techniques is understanding
frame buffers and what they are in a
nutshell is other things you can render
to other than just your screen because
typically you render to the back buffer
of your screen and then you swap it to
the front
and you're ready to go but you can also
render to things like the stencil buffer
and you can render to textures and some
other things and depending on
what you're doing you can take those
render areas and do things with them
and that's kind of it in a nutshell
it's a ton more to it obviously but i'm
like i said i'm no expert yet still
learning about it and this is going to
be critical for doing things like
reflections and mirrors
and
shadows and things like that you often
do additional render passes what people
are talking about when they talk about
render passes
is usually
that they're they're rendering to other
things and then they're using those
buffers they render to
to do other little special techniques so
yeah that's kind of where i at i'm at
with the engine right now is just
figuring out all these special
techniques
and figuring out what i can do and what
the best ways to add them in here
and
i also
i'm considering a lot of things you know
this this engine to be honest it's
to me it feels like a mess right now
although everything works and i very
carefully only commit things that that
work prop properly so
all the main branches things are
generally fine but there's a lot of
times where i'm off doing stuff
and breaking stuff and i have to abandon
my progress and start over
and i think sometime this year i am
going to
start a rewrite of this from scratch and
the main reason i'm going to do that is
because i need to redo the front end
interface now most people what they
eventually do
is they make something like
like a nice window editor
with sections for their assets and
sections to write stuff and do stuff and
you can see a lot of that especially on
you know a lot of people make these sort
of engines these days uh reddit.com
r game dev or maybe there's a slash
opengl one a lot of people are posting
their stuff over there and it's super
cool and the cherno another youtuber uh
way bigger than me by
magnitude's larger also
is making an engine hazel and his is
really cool
so
if you're if you want to see that kind
of stuff you can go there i don't think
i'm ever going to make an interface now
i kind of know how to using imgui and
stuff like that i understand it's
possible and what i could do to to do
that but it's not not really in my
interest uh i think instead of doing
that i'm just going to build the game i
want to make
because essentially that's where it gets
to and here's kind of the final result
of that day
that's that cube was great this circle
is it's just a growing circle it's
nothing special and here is
a model stenciled with normal so the
first one the cube was stenciled with a
scale and that one was skin stenciled
with normals and i was pretty happy with
it at this point so i started
just kind of shutting things down and
going on to the next step
and that was pretty much it for the
stream
and i thank you all that stopped by and
hung out it was nice seeing you guys
and hope to see you next time
and if you're watching this now i might
be streaming right now because i'm
planning on running a stream today i
don't know if i'll be coding or playing
tar cob or what
but you're welcome to stop by
and if you have amazon prime and haven't
used your your little twitch link and
free twitch sub consider using it on me
it would mean a lot very small streamer
so every little bit means a ton
and i appreciate you guys peace